c'est vendredi c'est les avis d'alexis
et bienvenue pour ce nouvel épisode
non parce que ça c'est un c'est mon
intro en fait j'en ai pas vendredi les
six heures on est mercredi fabien ça te
plaît cg oui alors vous connaissiez pas
c'est un trop bas vous avez qu'à
connaître la chaîne des avis d'alexis
qui toutes les semaines démontrent une
idée rossi lui pas du tout aller glisser
un pote à la base qui est magicien mais
qui à quelques années maintenant
maintenant ça fait cinq ans cinq ans a
ouvert une chaîne où il critique dans le
sens positif du terme un produit de
magie parce que vous un business de la
magie enfin preuve cliquez ici vous
allez découvrir sa chaîne alors c'est la
dernière vidéo du mois de du moins le
dernier mercredi du mois d'août donc je
me suis dit en termes de castets on va
cela fait un peu plus cool avec deux
casse-tête deux parce qu'ils sont plus
simples à résoudre et va pas se mentir
parce que j'aime ça je trouve que cette
fois elle va rien dire écoute on va pas
se mentir ce que la vie en ce moment
beaucoup d'entre eux whitson mais
aujourd'hui on va pas se mentir les ai
déjà craqué comme c'est son désaccord
voilà mais je me suis dit que en même
temps ça fait partie des simples que
j'adore ça c'est clairement mon casse
tête préféré à tel point que je trouve
que c'est un anti stress qui limite en
plus d'être un casse tête d'accor et lui
c'est juste un truc à la con que j'aime
bien qui fait rire et qui pèse lourd et
et voilà je me suis dit deux pour le
prix d'un
mais pourquoi pas depuis tu connais
c'est un petit peu mon niveau en
casse-tête lens par elle je me dis avant
de venir bonté nul on va essayer de
faire un petit peu être pas faux c'est
parfois c'est pas vrai mais voilà ce
mondial lequel tu as lease le fils
pourquoi est-ce qu'on garde pas le gros
pour la fin je serais plutôt chaud sur
les clés tu m'as dit que les clés
étaient tous préfet nous cook là on
commence par le gros d'accord ok parfait
de par le monde mais c'est sa sage de
magicien d'oz jeudi commençons par les
parce que lui il
il est sympa mais il ya moins
d'excitation millions vous on vous garde
ça pour la fin ok donc voilà le but du
jeu le but de ce casse tête qui est
vraiment
très sympa et d'enlever sa ok il est pas
d'une difficulté extrême mais en même
temps c'est un procédé que j'avais
jamais vu ailleurs
donc je trouve ça intéressant d'essayer
de faire ne pas subir donc toi tu les as
et montois tulle a craqué c'est donc moi
je l' ai craqué j'ai craqué ok donc
libre s'est regardé galéré tête je vais
commenter à lessard est sorti france et
la première vidéo où je n'agis pas bon
et bien bon courage et envie de te dire
bon courage mais en même temps ça va je
peux te donner un indice
le but du jeu n'est pas d'essayer de
désordre ça pour le sortir d'accord
toute façon j'avais pas là et l'espagne
donc en gros l'idée d'un écrou un blues
je sais jamais lequel est lequel le coup
les crocs le momentus est oui ça c'est
le boulon ça c'est les réseaux confond
tout le monde est en fait l'idée ce
serait dévissé dans le dessin en tout
cas on est attiré par la caisse parce
que là j'ai pas l'impression que ça
bouge nous fait mal air assez solidaire
aussi qu'il faut pas forcer et ils n'ont
pas forcé ne veut pas s'emballer
donc si j'essaie de prétendre davis et
ses 1 400 c'est comme ça normalement
c'est parti pour les points les gars
toujours plus y'avait pas aller voir sa
chaîne vous ne comprenez pas ce n'est
pas si on voit qu'il ya un trou là tout
à fait de se passer est là si on bouge
toi c'est ça a pas l'air d'être un seul
et même ensemble les croûtes et donc
comme tu as fait ta vidéo sur la boule
et le colonel je crois que oui il
fallait garder de différencier les deux
mois je pense qu'il faut toujours passer
par une phase d'exploration
effectivement donc là s'il ya un trou
ici ça veut dire que si ce patient voit
mais ça ça bouge alors que ça ça ne
bouge pas en boîte
tac tac tac et yappa genre davis en
vissant des services à on peut aller
plus loin on peut le davis et le vice et
on peut faire plein de choses je leur
bloc irakien jeunes qui veulent se faire
il est vraiment rebouc est par contre
c'est bloqué à temps ça peut être que
les blocs étaient chez toi tu étais en
montée et moi je suis descendu et là tu
peux plus non pas celle qu'on attend à
tension monte mais je sais pas comme
apple je vais faire juste ça ça va être
mon commentaire et de la vidéo c'est
chaud là tu dis est là là ça bloque mais
je suis remonté parce que j'avais des
bleus
donc en fait on sent on est d'accord que
toute cette partie lente sont fous rires
ouais ouais afrique et la chorale qui
s'est façonné c'est un légère attend
c'est vous avez pas vu le petit trou qui
vous a fait voir je vous ferai voir ça
sur mon instagram vous pouvez leur
ajouter ici je mets des petites vidéos
supplémentaires ou je fais des gros sous
un peu bad ass des casse tête donc je te
laisse me blessent il ya des mots qui
n'hésite pas moins qu'elle n'hésitait
pas non plus vraiment ce qu est ce que
c'est bien que tu le bon comme un truc
ça pour en faire deux mais en fait faute
de vidéos c'est ce que ta femme anticipé
parce que bien en fait
en fait c'est ça c'est quand on boit moi
quand je dis un truc simple c'est que
bon il est pas ou de difficultés duval
craquèrent mais comme fait des cas c'est
depuis très longtemps et en plus en ce
moment j'en fais énormément
forcément j'ai la mécanique et de thua
de métabolisme s'est adapté aux bêtes
ces cas c'est un peu comme si je te fais
un tour de cartes tu vas avoir des
espèces d'arbres est possible de
l'atteindre ça pourrait aussi çà çà çà
du coup la monarde des possibles est pas
énorme et dans tu vois c'est un peu la
marguerite des podiums joli bon c'est ça
ça commence donc j'ai réussi vraiment à
remonter tout à l'heure mais je sais pas
comment j'ai l'impression que y'a un
truc à bloquer ou
c'est horrible d'avoir l'impression que
tu y arrives tu à elle est en fait non
j'aimerais pas être à ta place et moi je
mais c'est bien mais c'est bien d'avoir
fait venir comme ça tu me ridiculise
après tu louvre après je pars je place
on n'en voit plus non regardez votre
console et regardent ils sont en train
de mettre des pouces en l'air mais j'ai
l'impression que ça vient mais je sais
pas trop il faudra jamais isolé cette
phrase jamais jamais de la vie alors à
temps il ya vraiment un trou donc ça
nous laisse partir toutes les phrases
les il est quand même tout est
interprétable alors à temps il faut 4 m
cuggia de faire de n'importe quoi faut
les seuils de cadres et l'assassin se
met ensemble ça veut dire que si je
pense que tu peux le tenir et à temps
hélas si je l'aimé ensemble à ça bouge
je crois que l'étape la plus longue je
suis allé pour l'instant mais j'ai
l'impression quand tu additionne fin
quand tu complémentarité les deux
morceaux de des roues luxe et les pros
ici je sais pas si on le voit mais ici
quand tu complémentarité de la sat
fait-on filetage et donc du conte
filetage et créé tu peux tourner et si
tu tournes est-ce que c'est beaucoup
mais moi j'ai envie de te dire un petit
peu comme dans mortal kombat fait les
cheveux là il ya plus qu'un normalement
si tu veux juste au bout mais j'ai
l'impression que ça bloque
car c'est trop beau d'aller jusqu'aux
trois pièces parfait et arabes en diable
la no2 sauront faire libérer donc en
fait t'as les croûtes bloqués dans le
boulot fait partie de l'écran qui est
bloqué dans le boulot et sita semble pas
les deux parties tuent crée pas ton fils
talent exactement en fait c'est pour ça
je dis moi j'ai jamais vu ça pour un
casse tête
c'est intéressant ça fait partie des
questions que je garde parce que je
trouvais l'idée aussi basiques que
malines tu vas célia puisqu'en fait en
plus ce n'est pas une forme complète
donc c'est ça qui fait qu'ils bougent
les accords tu vois et que tu es obligé
de le maintenir
effectivement si tu ne maintient pas
t'as pas tant filetage et donc il suffit
qu'ils s'ouvrent d'un tout petit
millimètre et bien tu es foutu une
voiture à ok d'accord et donc pour le
remettre de la même manière battu tu
dois remettre le filetage en place
claque et après tu es parti et après tu
prends le relai exactement comme tu as
fait c'est à dire donc tu maintiens
qu'il maintient bien en appuyant très
très fort mais écoulant plus ce n'est
pas 4 heures du matin ça fait pas trois
heures qu'on est dessus dessous
ce qui l'est déjà 83 heures alors qu'il
est à 6 heures moi je comprends plus
rien si cela impliquait et quoi de plus
beau que pour finir ce mois d'août
même s'il vous plaît tu ne te dernière
vidéo mais en bonus deux des castels des
mois de quoi de plus beau que de
terminer avec mon ami casse-tête préféré
taire que vous avez vu ce mois ci des
casse-têtes bien badass que j'ai adoré
tout mais lui est très couleurs déjà
chez un peu amoureux des clés parce que
les clés sahour quelque chose quand et
mystérieux etc
mais en plus celle ci une fois que tu as
réussi à l'ouvrir et à l'euro m après ça
devient limite tu sais toi tu fais du
rugby ce même plaisir habituel moi aussi
et on sait à quel point ça peut
déstressant en fête de fin au bitume une
fois tu sais bien le faire et d'ailleurs
si vous ne savez pas le faire je vous
recommande mon livre parce qu'il ya une
méthode de danse bien dans la
description
celui ci c'est le cas c'est ça peut
vraiment me déstresser de le prendre de
déférer de l'europe l'air d'accord donc
je te laisse essayer de réfléchir en
même temps qu alexis carrel et pose je
te laisse royaume
ok du coup c'est bien parce que encore
une fois tu mets pas trop de très longs
[Applaudissements]
messages devais avoir 4 ans alors ok
donc il ya deux clés l'une est fermé
l'autre est ouverte mais l'ouverture et
pas assez grande pour passer à l'est
quand tu as eu c est en même temps si ça
a été ça donc tous les morceaux de passe
pas en fait moi c'est mon frère qui est
des casse-têtes troll major chat
réfléchit donc là ça passe pas comme ça
est-ce que c'est pas une histoire du
genre tu tourne dans tous les sens et il
ya une espèce de chemin
il ya une histoire de trajet alors comme
d'habitude les deux casse-tête que vous
avez vues dans cette vidéo je vous mets
un lien dans la description pour que
vous puissiez les trouvez vous aussi on
a un bout de clés qui normale entre
guillemets il ya un bout de clés qui est
ciselé un endroit afin d'affiner je sais
pas si c'est parce que c'est une des
particularités parce que sinon tu as
time clé qui va représenter le qui va se
déplacer et l'autre clé représente le
chemin
le père trois exactement sa première clé
c'est plus grand que nous avons j'ai
l'impression que ça c'est complémentaire
avec ça toute l ouverture donc qui a un
moment faut l'amener dessus quoi tout à
fait je vais l'amener dessus tout de
suite bien tout de suite sur des pentes
louis c'est ça alors atteint parfois on
prend du temps oui tu n'en attend faut
que je suis est ce que si je suis là est
ce que si je suis en phase d'exploration
toujours pour les castels 24 ces gens
précise le docteur maboule faut pas
toucher les trucs mais là ça va bien et
il semble bien qu'ils ont fait un retour
mais j'ai enlevé ma part de faire chier
karamehmet de mouassa pas savait qu'on
allait faire pianon auquel la la la la
la
mme y ait là ça passe ok
ok ok donc là je peux aller retourne en
arrière il à revenir là ok aie aie aie
aie aie
donc là ta vie tu es passé par otg
passer par l'ouverture parce qu'ici
c'est un peu creusé en fait ouais c'est
un truc de hockey voilà la 90 des rushes
cac est annoncée non attends j'étais
parti dans votre sens
dans le muscle mais hélas le gâteau
l'idée c'est que je pensais avoir fini
donc c'est vrai non non non non pas du
tout genre je suis loin ou mais ça va
nantes a fait la moitié l'impression
d'avoir bataillé avec mon cerveau pour
réussir versa étude du nord mais
tranquille il reste 12 étant alors c'est
toujours une histoire du chemin d'accord
là ok la liesse hockey et il n'y a pas
un autre là un autre où il ya des trous
plus épais que d'autres et ne pas sortir
aussi cette phrase du contexte il est là
ou là non yes ou tu as fait la moitié du
parc c'est ce que j'ai dit depuis bâle
aidé par une lame de l'été c'est à dire
regardez là vraiment la première étape
d'un casse tête c'est de défaire et la
deuxième c'est de l'euro m et c'est ce
qui permet de prouver que c'était par
hasard mais franchement tu es tu bien
maintenant on revient à l'idée de quel
ingénieur de formation tu as vu quand
même fait pas du tout alors pour revenir
donc là je ressors voilà un film
intrigant mais est ce que c'est bien la
voir si on arrive on était assez
convaincu sellem archifaux que je le
ramène à l'intérieur parce qu'au départ
elle n'était pas sûre la noël était là
oui et on repasse de l'autre côté hockey
donc la normale même passage du coup
c'est ça donc là normalement je passe la
wii ce jeu tourne
sens contraire des aiguilles d'une
montre je fais trois jeux c'est pas du
tout ça se passe là normalement je
passais maintenant ce que je passais par
là je passais mais là je passe plus si
tu as quoi dresser mission qui donnerait
une voix tu me vois tu attends yes
c'est bon c'est bon ça fait ça fait les
catégories bravo à m6 d'être à merci
mais c'est ou d'être à 2-2 vraiment deux
millimètres de la sounna ouais c'est
clair et lens l'enchevêtrement du métal
des clés des formes d'épilepsie après
tuque et blot et puis après une fois que
tu la retenue oui je pense que c'est ça
c'est une histoire de pasteur née dessus
vous êtes appelés les gars c'est trop
bien ben j'ai réussi les faire c'est
déjà ça bah moi je suis fier de toi mon
pote je te propose qu'on ne refasse plus
jamais ensemble d'accords à la place je
te propose qu'on rebondisse sur 1000 et
que tu avais eu qu'on avait eue en
discutant à savoir des magiciens en plus
de donner énormément de trucs en magie
du coup avec toutes les vidéos tu fais
depuis cinq ans et le feu nous sommes à
100 pour que même temps que ça et
j'aimerais bien quand on rebondit sur
l'idée qu'un pays à savoir refaire ou
faire du moins un petit battle de magie
à la bigorneau et coquillages mais
version en bosnie tour avant ok waqar
dont voici un concept aussi le nom bah
oui faut pas drôle
et puis j'adore être bluffé aussi parce
que tu es quand et magicien tu apprends
et où étais tu perds un petit peu la
magie vraiment de là c'est vrai que ce
serait l'occasion de ce mois samba ba
écoute si ça te dit on se prend quelques
6 à leur dire je ne sais pas s'il est
enfoncé est ce que ça vous dit ou pas
vous avez un sondage qui apparaît devant
vous c'est à dire vous prenez un papier
un crayon à garder le sondage vous
envoyer l'adresse dans la del gusto
dépouillé et en fonction des résultats
on aura déjà fini de tourner ce sondage
là et ouais si cette manche on se donne
quelques semaines et tu vois on n'a pas
eu les clés c'est trop cool d'ici là
vous réussi de la chaîne des amis
d'alexis
évidemment vous pouvez laïque et cette
vidéo comme d'habitude vous abonner si
c'est pas encore fait un peu tout petit
rappel parce que ça c'est juste pour
vous si vous voulez venir l'olympia il
est grand temps vu le nombre d'objets
serait reste et moi aussi je serai ça
ils auront beaucoup se retrouver là bas
et pour rappel est aussi 40 villes
enfants plus de 40 villes maintenant
deux dates de tournée vous avez tous sur
le site www.ma devant l'écart tout
attaché pour les faire merci d'avoir été
là
ciao